باكستان حيث افاده مراسلنا هناك نقلا عن
مسؤول حكوميه في مقاطعه شمن شمن الحدوديه
مع افغانستان انا مدنيا قتل واصيب 16
اخرون جراء اطلاق النار من الجانب
الافريقي واضاف المتحدث انا من بين الجرحى
اربعه حالتهم حرجه وكان الجيش الباكستاني
اعلن في بيان ان مدنيين في بلده من
الحدوديه مع افغانستان قد تعرضوا للاطلاق
نار عشوائيا من الجانب الافغاني بينما ذكر
مصدر اخر ان اطلاق النار من الجانب
الافغاني جاء ردا على محاوله باكستانيه
لصيانه جانب من السياج الحدودي بين البنات
اما من الجانب الافغاني افاد مراسلنا في
كابول نقلا عن مسؤول حكومي انا اشتباكات
وقعت بين قوات افغانيه واخرى باكستانيه
قرب معبر اسفنج بولداك الحدودي بين
البلدين وقال مصدر الحكومي اخر للجزيره ان
الاشتباك ان الاشتباكات بين الجانبين خلفت
13 جريحا بينهم ثلاثه من افراد القوات
الاف الافغانيه